-Your mom -- I know she's
a big fan of your work.
She still come on set?
Still visits you?
-Oh, yeah. Kay Mac still
comes to sets. She still --
Her dream was to be
on "Golden Girls."
-Oh, wow.
-Somehow.
-That's a very noble dream.
-Hey, with a capital "N."
And so she --
I guess when she got around 70,
she decided, "You know what?
Maybe I'm not as limber
as I need to be
for 'Golden Girls' anymore.
I'm gonna start --
When I get to Matthew's
sets, I'm going to make
sure that I find..."
She always comes and goes,
"Who's the one with the money?
Who's the one
that can get things done?"
And I'm like, "That guy over
there or that woman over there."
And she'll go corner them.
And for about 12 years,
she had a pitch to
so-said "money-man" producer.
She had this great idea.
Listen to this. Brilliant.
"We need to remake
'The Graduate.'
I'll play the
Anne Bancroft role.
Matthew will be
the Dustin Hoffman role."
The first reaction's like,
"But don't you know...?"
And Mom always says, "Oh,
it's not that big of a deal.
I've seen it before."
[ Laughter ]
-Still unmade. It's one
of those unmade classics.
-Unmade, and, I mean, there was
a couple times people were like,
"That could make --
That could make some money."
So she stopped doing that at 82.
She's now 86.
She hasn't pitched
to any of the producers.
I don't know what
she's got on her mind now.
-Yeah, well, maybe this
"Golden Girls" thing
will come back around.
You never know. You're --
I want to know if this
is a true story.
Your father had a cockatiel?
-Yeah.
-Am I saying that right?
-Yeah, cockatiel.
-And there was a story
about a very harrowing evening
with the cockatiel.
-Yeah. This was a summer
where I was living with my dad.
Mom was not around.
I thought she was on an extended
vacation in Florida.
Now I understand
they were in the middle
of their second divorce.
-Your parents
got divorced twice.
-Divorced twice,
married three times.
-Oh, wow.
-So this was a long summer
where I just thought
Mom was on vacation.
So I'm living with my dad,
and we had this cockatiel.
And I would let it fly freely.
Well, he came home from work
one day, and then I came in.
And he was looking
for his cockatiel.
Where is it? Where is it?
Where is it?
It's not in the cage.
It's not anywhere to be found.
Go in the bathroom,
and it was circling
in the bottom of the toilet.
Not moving. Done.
-How does that even happen?
-I guess it flew in
and got under the rim.
-Okay, yeah.
-Couldn't see, couldn't get out.
Over and over and over.
Just laid in the water,
got soaking wet. I guess.
-Yeah.
-You know?
Being a cockatiel
detective expert.
[ Laughter ]
So, anyway, it's float--
And it's circling.
-"CSI: Birds."
-Coming to ya. 8:00 p.m.
So, oh, Dad immediately
starts weeping
and gets down,
drops to two knees,
and pulls this soaking-wet
cockatiel bird out.
I remember these tears
going down his face
and my dad holding this wet bird
and then suddenly putting
the bird's mouth --
his head in his mouth.
And he started going --
[ Exhales deeply ]
Like, at the perfect --
My dad was a big man.
6'4", 265. Big arms, big man.
And he did it with the
perfect amount of pressure
you would do to
a small bird that size.
Just enough
to blow his lungs out.
And he sat there,
and he kept going --
Tears were coming down his face.
And damned if after
about 45 seconds...
the bird starts flapping.
Bup-bup-bup-bup-bup...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the movie.
-That's cool.
-Oh, well, cheers to that.
And cheers to the bourbon.
And the film.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Thanks for being back.